alors professeur dans un lycée
professionnel à créteil 11 ans
d'expérience tu touches 2300 euros net
par mois avec les primes pas assez sa
tête obligés de cumuler ton statut de
professeur professeur principal et
heures supplémentaires pour toucher plus
de salaire de moins en moins de gens
volaient trabzon rectifie heures
supplémentaires j'ai pas je les ai pas
choisis
depuis le nouveau ministère j'ai été
obligé de les prendre d'accord alors est
obligé de voilà donc de faire tout ça
pour essayer d'en sortir et tu dis que
de moins en moins de gens veulent être
prof
il ya de moins en moins de gens qui
veulent être prof et même dans ceux qui
veulent être prof
il ya de plus en plus de stagiaires qui
démissionnent tellement ça devient
compliqué je vais vous donner un exemple
très simple j'ai été en salle
d'informatique il ya deux jours avait
une grosse bassine noirs ici pour
récolter les petites gouttes qui tombent
du plafond informatique électricité sûr
je pense que c'est assez clair c'est ça
actuellement les conditions dans
lesquelles on enseigne et après avant de
continuer sur ce que j'ai à dire je
voudrais juste préciser que le membre du
gouvernement est donc parti avant que
moi je pars c'est là toute la
considération qu'on apprend les
enseignants non parce qu'il avait on
avait promis de libérer à 23h déjà y
rester un peu plus longtemps que prévu
voilà il a dit qu'il aimait dialogue moi
j'ai entendu ça mais bon non mais voilà
il peut y reviendra peut-être mais c'est
vrai que là il s'était pour coupe
exprimé avec beaucoup de personnes et là
il devait partir à 23 heures on l'a
lâché à 23h30 déjà voilà il nous a
accordé de 30 minutes de plus et ils
étaient obligés de partir alors tu dis
que on voit les choses se dégrader nos
des kimonos conditions sont déplorables
on se retrouve à faire d'autres travaux
qui ne sont pas les nôtres on assiste à
la destruction du service public est de
moins en moins de gens aussi sont formés
avec trouverais ça parce qu'ils reposent
en moi qui veulent être professionnel
avait pas que ça il ya d'abord le fait
que avant il y avait une formation sert
que les gens rentraient en licence passé
le concours et après il avait deux ans
de formation de par l'éducation
nationale où il avait des petites heures
de cours de temps en temps et après
l'analyse 16 heures de cours pour
pouvoir les gérer maintenant on demande
aux gens d'avoir un master donc ça veut
dire que leurs formations allaient à
leur charge elle est plus à la charge de
l'état
finalement et du coup ils se retrouvent
après en classe dans les situations qui
n'avait pas du tout anticipé
souvent les gens qui ont fait un master
on va se dire les choses ils viennent
pas des quartiers défavorisés mais
souvent leur premier poste
ils l'ont dans le 94 cents dans le 93 à
l'académie de créteil
et là il tombe des nues parce qu'ils
s'attendaient pas à ça d'accord temps et
c'est pour ça qu'il démissionne parce
qu'on a des conditions difficiles on
fait autre chose que ce qu'on pense
faire parce que c'est plus le même
maîtres
et ça a changé et on n'a pas permis aux
gens d'entrer en douceur entre
parenthèses dans le métier en faisant
les choses correctement et en les
formant au départ donc déjà assez
difficile et le départ mais en dehors de
ça même quand on est depuis longtemps on
a des horaires élastiques ça alors que
moi j'ai entendu beaucoup c'est ça qui
est difficile à estimer les enseignantes
à un petit temps de travail panda
beaucoup de vacances concrètement le
présentateur du jt il bosse pas 45
minutes par jour il le prépare
il ya des choses autour et bien nous
c'est la même chose et sauf que les gens
ce qu'ils savent pas c'est que plus ça
va plus on n'a pas que des choses qui
sont autour des cours c'était le cas au
départ fallait préparer ses cours
fallait aussi aller au musée aller au
ciné savoir ce qui se passe autour parce
qu'on est censé avoir une culture
générale sur et pas juste amener un
court parce que c'est un bouquin peut le
faire sauf que maintenant en plus on a
plein de réunions pour vérifier qu'on
fait bien ce qui a été décidé alors faut
que cette ascension à ce que je dis
parce que maintenant on a un devoir de
réserve il ya des choses que j'aurais pu
le droit de dire depuis très peu de
temps
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a fait grève
de l'année dernière on se retrouve à à
travailler avec des tâches qui sont
purement administratif parce que avant
il y avait le siec qui gérait les
examens est de plus en plus avaient tiré
par l'elysée d'autant plus avec la
nouvelle réforme du bac où il ya un bon
bonne partie des examens qui se déroule
maintenant dans les incidents et les
lycées avec les profs d'accord donc ça
c'est pour le secondaire on s'est
compris alors mais c'est partout pareil
hein juste
estelle toit et non que tu es prête à
faire grève jusqu'à obtenir une réponse
du gouvernement
la réponse apparemment on l'aura
mercredi puisque on a eu quand même
cette info voilà donc edouard philippe
va donner une réponse mercredi
donc jusqu'à mercredi tu vas faire grève
en fait le les retraites c'est la cerise
sur le gâteau c'est tellement on est
d'accord qui est un gâteau déjà au
départ il ya des tas de fois on n'a pas
été entendu et à chaque fois qu'il ya
une nouvelle réforme est juste pas être
d'accord la réponse et vous n'avez pas
compris la réforme
encore une fois on nous a dit qu'on
allait nous augmente et on sait pas de
combien ça peut être du 30 euros par
mois on vous a déjà fait le coup si si
on vous augmente 30 euros par mois ça
change pas la vie de quiconque
aujourd'hui enfin si malheureusement et
des gens pour que ça change la vie
mahler chaud mais pour nous c'est vrai
que 30 euros ça va pas tout changer
d'accord et à côté de ça
on nous dit bon vous êtes rentré à pas
grand chose vous finissez a pas beaucoup
parce que j'ai vu des salaires
mirobolants de rohff sur lci mais je
n'ai jamais eu pire même enfin il
n'aurait pas le 3 mai 6ème mahmoudi et à
la retraite à plus tard et encore moins
la sauce c'est difficile à entendre
quand même donc pour ce qui concerne la
grève
nous on n'a pas le même poids que les
trois ans quand on fait grève bien je
suis imaginé bien encore plus en lice et
peut-être qu'en maternelle et en
primaire ça un poids et salue sa sentant
peu chez nous beaucoup moins en donc on
attend de voir qu'est ce qu'on va
choisir comme type de mobilisation il
est clair qu'on va rester mobilisés
maintenant on se retrouve demain nous on
fonctionne en collectif et on va
discuter du type de mobilisation
maintenant au niveau national de toute
façon il ya des préavis syndicaux donc
en fonction des établissements ça serait